I've instructed the Commissioner of
Parks and Recreation to issue
regulations that would ban outdoor
feeding in all city parks earlier this
year Philadelphia the City of Brotherly
Love passed a new law making it illegal
to feed the homeless in public joining
New York Las Vegas Orlando and other
cities that have tried to enact similar
bans so are these new rules really
helping the homeless brian jenkins leads
a nonprofit called chosen 300 which
among other things gives food to
homeless people on the street he says
that while ideally the homeless would go
to soup kitchens for all their meals
that's simply not realistic there's
people who are not able to go indoors
because if they go into enclosed spaces
with a lot of people they can cause
fights they cannot cause harm to
themselves and also harm to others so
we're able to reach those folks so that
way they can sit in the park by
themselves not being bothered by anybody
but they can get the right to eat and
that's so important because if they
don't get the right to eat then they're
gonna do whatever they have to do to get
something to eat without a hint of irony
Philadelphia Mayor Michael Nutter said
that when charities give homeless people
fresh food on the street there's a risk
of food poisoning because food served
outdoors often isn't handled properly he
also argues that often the real problem
is mental illness as the mayor told a
federal judge they're not just hungry
they have other needs jenkins says that
sometimes feeding homeless people
outdoors is the best way to address
those other needs we're not just giving
them the meal we're giving them our
affection our cares are love and sharing
hope with them and then also referring
them to services that are so valuable to
them to move them towards a state of
self-sufficiency so what's really behind
these new laws making Philadelphia look
pretty for visitors the ACLU which sued
and won a temporary injunction against
the new law says the real reason for the
ban is protecting the city's image as a
tourist destination since the biggest
gathering spot for Philly's homeless
population is adjacent to its
world-renowned art museums these laws
are designed to really eliminate people
out of plain view so that we can have
this idea that the city doesn't have a
homeless problem you have to solve the
problem and not just move the problem
the federal lawsuit will come to trial
early next year in both the city and
Bryan
Jenkins group are working to resolve the
standoff out-of-court whether that
settlement will allow voluntary
organizations to do what they think is
best
remains to be seen for reason TV I'm
Nicholas
[Music]